schon wieder müssen wir eine
katastrophale folgen des klimawandels
vermelden die forschungsteams weltweit
schon seit einiger zeit kopfzerbrechen
bereitet es geht um ein meeresgebiet vor
alaska in dem sich zwei wassermassen
übereinander stapeln und das schlimme
forschungsteams sind es tickende
zeitbomben die das wetter ausgerechnet
hier in deutschland massiv beeinflussen
können pixum science fiction herzlich
willkommen
[Musik]
oben ist dieser meeres wirbel besonders
kalt und leicht unten dagegen warm und
salzig und forschungsteams sind sich
sicher dieser merkwürdige meeres wirbel
ist eine tickende zeitbombe
wenn die konstellation instabil wird
werden die wassermassen nicht nur die
arktis dramatisch verändern sondern auch
das wetter hier bei uns in deutschland
konkret geht es um die beaufort see ein
teil des nordpolarmeeres das vor alaska
liegt die existiert ein gigantisches
strömungs system auch sofort wirbel
genannt er dreht sich vor alaska im
kreis und zwar im uhrzeigersinn dieser
merkwürdige wird mehrere wirbel besteht
aus zwei sehr unterschiedlichen
wasserkörper die sich übereinander
stapeln die wassermassen oben sind zum
einen sehr leicht und kalt es sammelt
sich eine art leichte wasser linse und
genau dies sorgt dafür dass dort meeres
als lange zeit im wirbel festgehalten
wird über jahre hinweg so das eis
deutlich dicker und stabiler wird als in
anderen regionen
diese linse verdeckt die tiefer
liegenden schichten die salzig und warm
sind die folge die arktis selbst zeigt
sich trocken und kalt der nordatlantik
dagegen ist waren fest steht also dass
die auswirkungen des meeres wirbel somit
auch noch an den europäischen küsten zu
spüren sind zudem weiß man auch dass
sich das verhalten des strömungs systems
meist zuverlässig voraussagen lässt
seitdem es beobachtet wird hat sich sein
zyklus etwa alle fünf bis sieben jahre
umgedreht dann floss das kalte leichte
wasser plötzlich in den nordatlantik der
zustrom des warmen wassers aus dem
golfstrom wird so langsamer und ganz
europa kühlt sich ab ihr ahnt es was
parallel mit dem warmen tiefen wasser
passiert es steigt auf und macht die
arktis feuchter und wärmer doch eine
internationale forschungsgruppe hat
jetzt eine spannende entdeckung gemacht
demnach sammelt sich unter der linse aus
kaltem leichten wasser eine um
das haben wohl messungen in der
benachbarten region chiemsee gezeigt
demnach hat sich der wärme gehalt der
tieferen wasserschichten in den letzten
jahren sogar verdoppelt dieses
meeresgebiet ist sehr flach und wird
durch die sonne stark aufgeheizt
mittlerweile sogar fünfmal so intensiv
wie noch vor 30 jahren und das hat
folgen für die süßwasser kappe der
sofort sehen denn das warme salzige
wasser sinkt darunter und punkt das
tiefe wasser mit wärmeenergie voll und
das ist ein wirklich waghalsiges
konstrukt nach angaben des
forschungsteams könnte das im fall der
fälle zu fatalen konsequenzen führen
angenommen diese zusätzliche wärme würde
an die oberfläche kommen könnte das
gesamte meeresgebiet in dieser region
eisfrei bleiben und das könnt ihr euch
selbst vorstellen hätte nicht nur
kurzfristige folgen für die arktis zu
diesem neuen erkenntnissen kommt die
tatsache hinzu dass sich der meeres
wirbel seit fast 15 jahren seltsam
verhält denn er dreht sich schneller und
sammelt dabei meersalz namens wasser am
so gelangt immer mehr süßwasser in die
kalte blase und so gelten nicht nur die
warmen wasser massen als tickende
zeitbombe denn das kalte wasser könnte
auch extreme veränderungen bewirken und
zwar einige tausend kilometer entfernt
nämlich im nordatlantik denn nach
angaben der fachleute würde dorthin das
kalte wasser der ostsee fließen wenn
sich die strömung umkehren würde
so war es zumindest in der vergangenheit
doch da waren die wassermengen bei
weitem nicht so gewaltig die heutzutage
und damit würde auch das wetter hier bei
uns in europa und eben auch in
deutschland dramatisch kippen denn dann
wäre europa wohl jahrelang vom golfstrom
system abgeschnitten und eben auch von
der tropischen wärme die das system mit
sich bringt sehr kalte winter wären die
folge das weiss man noch aus den 70er
jahren durch ein ähnliches ereignis
damals war der salzgehalt im
nordatlantik dramatisch gesunken und
hatte für extrem kalte winter gesund da
war es hier ganz ruhig in deutschland
extreme kälte wie in sibirien mit 7 -20
grad celsius legte deutschland wirklich
lahmt das fazit der fachleute also ist
erschreckend sowohl die aufgeheizten
wassermassen unter der süßwasser
diese als auch die wassermassen darüber
könnten fatale auswirkungen haben nur
dass andere regionen im fadenkreuz
dieser wasserbomben stünden das
forschungsteam der aktuellen studie
jedenfalls hat sich ist sich sicher dass
der wirbel früher oder später instabil
wird und die bomben platzen und
schließlich gelangen die wärme des
tiefenwassers zwangsläufig irgendwann
einmal an die oberfläche der
nasa-wissenschaftler alec partie sagt
für den beiden szenarien die folge in
europa würden zwar nicht aussehen wie
der katastrophenfilm the day after
tomorrow
aber tatsache ist dass wir es einfach
nicht wissen ob so ein krasses statement
wird man selten von einem
wissenschaftler also warum mal gucken
was da passiert hier geht es weiter mit
dafür drauf kriegen nasa video schock
taktisches eis schmilzt rasant ja wenn
er kein video mehr zu diesem und allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
folgt mir auf rezept dafür hier klicken
nur da bekommt ihr von mir vor allen
anderen das neueste video ganz
unabhängig von der abo box hier auf
youtube
ja und trotzdem natürlich gerne auch ein
abo da lassen und nicht die immer auf
die glocke vergessen bis dann bleibt
banken